how would you say the season 2 vibe is
in one word fire here working all the
elements in the eye of the storm
hurricane fire
we are here for another fabulous edition
of housewives happy hours and cheers to
Real Housewives of Potomac here we have
Monique here yes
season two new yeah I live in in the
heat of the moment so I was thrown into
like the lake of fire but it was fun you
know I'd like to be around by name
deployments here's to a lake of fire
full of famous women as a fan I'm sherry
well that's what I mastered it is nasty
okay I have four homes
you go girl she got that see [ __ ] out
your husband in his bank account
you wouldn't be here at least I'm still
married to my eddakath it's completely
gone on yeah totally lost it so free to
take a swim over there I'm sorry you're
running I am only human and if you
scratch me I'm a scratch yeah who's the
biggest you know what stir the season
well no actually you're giving me a run
for my money can you believe it
ashley is Ashley yes she's like this
she's gonna yeah she's like yes [ __ ]
everybody yes yes if something smells
fishy I'm gonna call it cheers to see
them to a Potomac return of the Mack I
love that cheers to you
[Music]